you you do this new movie agreed which
is its it's an interesting movie because
it is quite a serious subject you know
it is also very funny in moments and so
I think it sort of walks that razor's
edge between being compelling and about
something very serious but about your
character is someone who's this
over-the-top wealthy person who's
completely lost perspective
yeah it's we just wanted to talk about
like I play a cat who's obnoxious
flamboyant nasty unpleasant bullying but
funny yeah I watching them like I see my
beautiful
so he's horrible distinguishes us is he
has this character has this incredibly
crazy spray on looks like a spray-on tan
yeah well it's well I playing a player
that's a tycoon and a lot of
billionaires you know they spot these
all year round towns because they're
normally in their tax havens which are
floating palaces that cost 400 million
dollars and so they get they go brown
because they're on deck one yeah and
then they throw the price of an SUV at
their mouth so that their teeth come
your teeth are insane in this movie I
don't know if we've the teeth are
practically glowing this character has
all the money in the world and he's
clearly spent a fortune having these
massive fake well I I don't have that in
England you know we sort of try we try
and do the best we can without teeth oh
you Americans but but I had to look like
someone from LA sir i I just blows
so I love
I just love that
[Laughter]
can't tell you how many meetings I've
had you be it you've gotta meet this guy
is a really good corporate lawyer he'll
understand how to help you and he'll
come in and they'll have those tina and
he has to put shades on to talk it's
insane it's insane greed as I said it's
a I would say it's a I wouldn't even
describe it as say necessarily a comedy
its its comedic elements but what you're
talking about is a real problem
yeah we're talking that the movies about
we're talking about the fashion industry
and the fact the high street clothes
cost you know you can go and buy a
t-shirt for ten dollars and we look at
supermodels and famous actors and and
and you know pop stars yeah wearing
these clothes and we think well we're
gonna buying a bit of glam or buying a
bit of empowerment but really these
clothes are made by garment workers in
factories in Sri Lanka and Bangladesh
and they get paid four dollars a day for
the companies like Zara and people like
Walmart and and these companies were you
know the they're worth like 20 billion
or 60 billion sometimes in the case
Walmart like 170 billion and these
garment workers are paid a pittance and
what we do in the movies we marry those
two things together because so one week
was shooting on a super yacht on Monaco
yeah and the next we were shooting in a
garment factory in Sri Lanka yeah and
and and what we try and say with the
movies it's quite it's not actually that
complicated it's like the reason that
the super-rich are super rich is because
a bunch of people are super poor yes
that's that you just connect the dots
yeah and we just wanted to talk about
that and put it on the map me people
think about where it's not just about
cheap clothes but it's about high street
fashion but it could be about any
industry really and it's not that we're
sort of like pointing the finger saying
these people are bad it's just that the
system that we live in makes those
things happen yeah maybe parcel and we
talk about other stuff we talk we all
talk about the we talk about the
environment we talk about gender
politics we talk about diversity and all
this stuff that's really important but
the song elephant in the room is like is
poverty and the huge gaps in the rich to
the poor it cuts between your character
who's throwing a the movie takes place
when he's throwing a 60th birthday party
for himself
and literally he's he's spending like
tens of millions of dollars on his
birthday party and you contrast that
with how he's getting the money yeah we
had like refugee we had Syrian refugees
in the movie who played themselves and
the garment workers played themselves
and then you know we had this this the
party where he he'd make several dress
in fats it's sort of he has a sort of
sick sense of humor I mean which makes
you laugh but it's also sort of quite
I'm not just like for example the
refugees are on the beach and they're
spoiling the view of the guest of his
party and someone says you can't you
can't move then they've come you know
thousands of miles he says well if I
come all that way they might mind going
a few extra yards down the me yeah yeah
he's so your character is an incredible
prick but he's got teeth for days yeah
we have a clip here from greed and I
believe this is where your character has
actually been been been brought up to
sort of he's being held accountable by I
believe the British government oh yeah
for some of his transgressions it's fine
it was based it's based on a real guy
called Philip green in England loosely
and he was hauled up before the House of
Commons he was quite a flamboyant guy so
loosely based on him but yeah he was
subject to the kind of scrutiny that
super-rich people very rarely yeah I
have to endure let's take a look at this
clip from green this is an investigation
into my tax affairs I pay what I have to
and no more - not stupid if you want to
chase people avoiding tax why don't you
go after the big boys I mean look at
Apple look at Amazon Starbucks why are
you chasing me right yes it's not them
suggest you google it mr. chairman
there's another company how much tax
didn't Google Play not very much if you
don't believe me talk to Bono he's
avoided hundreds of millions attacked by
claiming that you two are based in
Holland doesn't stop him going around
the world in your Nan's
sunglasses proclaiming about ending
poverty or whatever this is him in the
Daily Mail you'd be stupid not to try
and cut your tax bill says Bono
yeah quarrels are 9-1 I'm sure yeah I'm
sure bun oh well I'm sure Bono will
survive a bit of criticism from someone
in an independent movie yeah yeah yeah
we'll see good luck to you
greed is in theaters tomorrow in New
York and Los Angeles it'll be in
theaters nationwide on Friday March 6
keep Coogan always an honor
[Applause]